Mr. T with no hair and a baby giving the peace sign
in the womb.
It's episode of 39 IMG!
When tweety bird gets
old, you're gonna have this.
And it's amazing how little
information we need to see familiar objects.
It's also amazing than an iPhone can fall
13,500 feet from a sky diver's pocket
and still receive phone calls.
Well, this looks safe.
Oh.
And this looks sad.
Oh. This looks cool. Ohhhh.
This rock
is sad and so is food like this pear.
I mean, how could you eat such sad food?
Try a hot dog instead.
No, no, no. A hot dog, like really hot.
Pepperoni sweater hot.
Prefer your dog to be a mouse pad?
Well, you might also prefer your rock paper
scissors to be more complex.
Rock Paper Scissors Lizard Spock is popular,
but there's also Pirate Zombie Monkey
Ninja Robot or
this game which uses 15 different
items.
And don't worry, there's also RPS25.
Each item has an equal chance of winning
and yes, there are explanations for each.
If remembering 25 items is too much,
don't worry, there is a flash game version.
Here's a Middle Earth Map dress and is
that Steve Buscemi on your dress or are
you just really saggy to see me?
Sorry if that came across like a pickup line.
It's just
I mustache you a question.
Can eyebrows
your computer?
Alright, look, no more puns. At least
not until after the soap opera.
BuzzFeed showcased some
unnecessary signs.
"Keep off the
grass" and yeah, no one has to tell me that.
So instead, here are some famous people
eating ice cream.
Enjoy.
Let's get charty.
I love these two
huge charts.
One is all about the atom, the nucleus,
the distances electrons are away from it, fission, fusion.
It's great. And here's one from National
Geographic that puts our universe
in perspective.
This graph distributes rage faces
according to happy, sad and degree of
energy. Now, you'll never use the wrong one.
And these maps show the most popular
first
names by country.
The greasy stain on this receipt has a man's
face in it. And these chairs look like they're sinking.
Their bottom halves have been painted
as a projection like shadows,
so that from the right angle
they come together. This
is the Firefox logo and this
is V838 Monocerotis, possibly
the largest star known to man.
I leave you
with 241543903.
Google it, click images. Ta-da.
Search engines at work. You can like us
on Facebook to show your friends how
cool you are.
Click here to see all 38 other episodes of IMG!,
in case you've missed any.
And as always,
thanks for watching.